So what are the benefits of being a TA?
There's certainly a lot of work that can be put into being a TA, but what are the benefits?
Some of them would be boosting your own skills.
There's a whole range of skills that you would develop as a TA.
One is your coding skills, since the process of explaining how to code to other people
solidifies your own understanding of that coding process.
There's the collaboration component.
There is this idea that coding is all about doing things individually; staying up all
night, drinking lots of coffee.
Actually I would argue, as many others do, that it's a lot more about collaboration;
being able to communicate effectively with others is absolutely essential.
And again being a TA is all about collaboration and so your collaboration skills will improve.
There's using all the online tools.
We might take these for granted to an extent but practice with different kinds of online
chat and asynchronous forums and all the hangout stuff from Google; screen share etc.
will improve your online tech skills.
As you know you're working with a team of TA's and students which can help develop your
team skills.
And of course all the things from the course such as Software Engineering, Agile development
and so on.
Particularly to the extent that you get involved in projects with students and the Agile Ventures
projects that we have going on in the background
There's also the conflict resolution skills you'll develop - are developing - when students are getting
at each others throats, or even other TA's getting at each others throats :-)
Helping to resolve those conflicts is something you can put on your resume.
There's the experience of working with remote developers from all around the world. We're
overwhelmed by all the different nationalities and spoken languages that we have represented
in our community.
It really is a fantastic environment in which to show how you can collaborate with an international
distributed team.
So there's all that benefit in potentially boosting your skills.
And not only that, we've got certificates too!
These are the official Engineering Software-as-a-Service textbook certificates, which
are also backed by AgileVentures.
We've got an example of the level 1 certificates there so you'll get one of these for completing
this course.
You'll get the level 2 certificate if you participate as a TA in the 169.1 course and
perform a sufficient level of student supporting activity every week over the seven or so weeks
of that course, or equivalent work on an AgileVentures project.
And if you do the same thing again in the 169.2 course then you can get a level 3 certificate
and these are all things that go into your portfolio.
Having a portfolio, a collection of your projects and achievements is important for your future
job and university applications.
You'll be able to add to your portfolio that you've been a teaching assistant for the 169
Engineering Software as a Service course; that you've completed this Distributed Teams
course and gained these certificates.
There's also the Agile Ventures projects that you work on as part of this which could also
go into your portfolio, since as you know Agile Ventures is a project incubator for
open source projects.
The big thing really is about giving back to the community.
It's been fantastic the last few years as many leading universities have made lots of
their learning materials and courses available for free.
I think pretty much everyone agrees this has made the world a better place.
So by giving back to the community you could help in the process of making this world one
in which education is available to everyone without hindrance.
Also you can get really big personal satisfaction from helping other people
Some people say that it's about becoming a star.
We're all stars you know, we're all radiating the light of human compassion.
It's that connection with people and helping other people that's makes things worthwhile
really.
So I'm looking forward to seeing you in the rest of the course and hopefully as TAs in
the MOOC or participants in Agile Ventures.